[Música]
o clube o palco matar nela depois a
quilo de picanha e comi uma carne dinho
panela e o pedacinho de lasanha
só agora que eu limpei receber vou olhar
pra quê dia tá pra quê se eu vejo uma
coxinha eu sei que eu vou comer uma
olhar pra quem e está pra quem eu vejo
uma coxinha eu sei que eu vou te comer
vou olhar pra que um dia tá pra quem eu
vejo uma coxinha eu sei que o gol do
meio campo molhado é e dia a proteína se
eu vejo uma coxinha eu sei que eu
proclamei e dormiu pouco morta dela
depois o quilo de lasanha ficou nenhuma
carne de panela
é pois um espeto de picanha show agora
que eu vim perceber o olhar pra quem ia
tá pra quê se eu vejo uma coxinha eu sei
que eu vou comer olhar pra quem ia tá
pra quem eu vejo uma coxinha eu sei que
o ponto 6 ou maior pra ter que ia tá pra
quê se eu vejo uma coxinha eu sei que o
povo lê vou malhar pra quem ia tá pra
quem é seu beijo na cozinha enquanto
essas instâncias do show como é que faz
com o corpo todo
[Música]